hi I'm RuPaul Charles no you're not I'm
RuPaul Charles
hi I'm Izzy gene and I am RuPaul and we
start together in the new Netflix show
AJ and the Queen but today we are
Entertainment Tonight correspondence I
told you I wasn't strong enough to
handle this but you you did it anyway
you are strong enough you stood up to
those shady Queens of the club that
wasn't me that was Ruby you are Ruby why
was I the best person to play aj you
know it had to do with energy we saw a
lot of kids for the role of AJ and when
I saw your audition tape I thought oh
this kid's got it and then when I met
you in person the chemistry we have
together was so perfect I mean ah there
is AJ oh you're gonna do your moves now
how much are you like AJ she on the
inside has a lot of personality like me
and she can be kind at times he can be
loving at times she shows a lot of
passion different passions but we do
show a lot of passion but you're not a
thug are no because AJ she's really you
know come on she's the thug right yeah
do you have any qualities that are
thuggish I mean have you ever had a
fight at school or anything like that
not this way I'll just say that about a
fistfight over here
I'm his bodyguard
Ajay's character is very a butch little
kid right but then at the end of the day
when you be ready to go home you'd let
your hair down and your girl just in
pink and you'd have sparkly things all
over ya so I got a Barbie van for
Christmas one of our producers got it
for me and when our costume designer she
said who's that for and our producer is
he and she's like oh right I forgot she
was such a girly girl and I'm like wow
that happen you know good my job you are
good at your job and because you sell
the character of AJ so well AJ is a real
thug but as the episodes go on you see
that there is a heart there and that
this character has learned to protect
her serve ulnar ability with being a
tough a tough person
you play ruby-red and they Jay and
McQueen and you guys seem a lot alike
how would you say she's different from
you I would say that ruby red is more
gullible than RuPaul is you know ruby
red falls for a smooth-talking
good-looking con artist I may be tempted
to fall for a good-looking con artist
but I RuPaul would probably not
[Music]
[Applause]
why did it take you so long for you to
star in your own TV show that's a great
question I'm so glad you asked that you
know I've been looking for the perfect
vehicle perfect role to do that with and
this just happened to be the one and you
know you're very young you know what
happens is timing is everything you know
but you got to stay in the game long
enough for your number to come up you
know you're very fortunate out right out
of the bat you've got this great big
show on Netflix you know to sustain a
career for a very long time you have to
you have to pace yourself but you also
have to stay interested in doing doing
the work how did you have this idea for
the show well I met with Michael Patrick
King and we wanted to work together so
within 15 minutes of our meeting he
asked me what the emerging audience on
Drag Race was and I said well 13 year
old suburban girls are the emerging
audience and then we talked some more
and he had a poster from a movie that I
love called Sullivan's Travels and I
said I love that movie said I love that
movie so there we had the idea of
because Sullivan's Travels is a picture
about the two people who go on the road
together so we mixed the idea of a 13
year old and a road picture together and
that's how we got AJ in the Queen of
course AJ in this case is only ten years
old okay I've got a question for you how
much did you know about RuPaul before
you got cast in AJ and the Queen I
actually didn't know a lot I knew about
your music and I knew what you look like
I knew what you looked like and dragged
yeah but I didn't want your show but
that's basically all I knew and to be
fair when we met you were 9 years old so
I think at that point drag race had been
on the air for nine years or something
like that so you know that's a that's an
easy pass yeah
being nine years old yeah yes how long
did it take you to get into drag well
you know we could probably do it I would
get there at five o'clock in the morning
on drag days five o'clock and we'd start
I could I think I was on set
sometimes at 10 o'clock to start filming
but you know we could do it in three and
a half we could do it do I hear two and
a half do I hear one and a half yeah
you've got I can meet that challenge
yeah
I won't look that great but I can meet
that challenge
oh did you ever get into drag while you
were there like you say you were born
naked and the rest is drag oh dear
peril but all the time on set I would
drag you weren't the whole time I'm a
dragon
what did you learn about me on the set
because we're together the whole time
side by side for six months learning
lines you telling me stories about your
friends yeah and you wanting to play
that pittypat game every day there was a
new type of han jive game that I learned
so what did you learn about me on the
set I learned that you have an amazing
memory let's just say that being able to
memorize all of those lines and also
that you are powerful that you are
strong you are amazing that you are
helpful not just to me but to everybody
on set you were very helpful to
everybody you were so kind you never
ever ever made anybody feel degraded or
like they were nothing even if they did
feel like they were nothing you made
them feel like they were everything hmm
and you were just the best person that
could have been on set for everybody
that's very kind thank you very much
it's a very nice thing you say I love
that what did you learn from me on set
well I learned from you that it's always
important to be kind at all times
because we work long hours sometimes 15
16 even longer you know the night that I
did the wet t-shirt contest I don't know
what time you went home but I think I
got home at 2:30 in the morning and I
had to shoot a commercial the next day
but I learned from you to not take it
all too seriously
because if I flubbed a line or if anyone
flipped line you would always say it's
okay you're doing good yeah that was
like that was like our inside joke on
set but it's it's great advice and and
it's important to remember that because
what we're doing with the show is
hopefully entertaining people and making
them think and giving them something to
laugh about and to be grateful about and
so for us to do that work we have to
remember those things and to not be so
hard on ourselves so I learned that from
you and I loved going to work every day
and being reminded that this is such a
lovely job to have and that we're very
fortunate to have it what was your
favorite thing about filming the show my
all-time favorite thing about shooting
the show was that I would be able to be
part of this crazy adventure and that I
would be able to meet amazing people but
the adventure from the beginning all the
way to the end was something that you
would stick for yeah that you wouldn't
just abandon immediately it was it
wouldn't be just like Oh a pass yeah I
felt so connected when I watch I mean
ice when I saw the script I was just
laughing I couldn't stop laughing just
believe three pages that I got I
couldn't stop laughing it was well you
could tell from your audition tape
because you were so invested in it and
you were able to bring something to the
audition that no one else had there was
a sort of a roughness and a playfulness
and you couldn't help but fall in love
with this character with your
interpretation of it you know my
favorite thing about coming to work
every day was you and the fun we had
because we had a lot of fun and then our
natural chemistry together and we
actually that was present for the
audition that we did together our
natural chemistry we feel so good
together and then of course being able
to work with Michael Patrick King now
you're only 11 years old now but Michael
Patrick King has a long history very
successful history in writing and
producing and directing and so to work
with someone who is so talented so
marked so passionate he laughs he cries
he screams he's there which gives us
everyone who works with him permission
to do the same thing and it's so freeing
to do that so those are my favorite
things and also we got to film on the
same soundstage as judy garland's a star
is born and we got to film on the same
sound amazing the same sound stage as
Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf two great
movies that were filmed on stage 21
where we we made our home that's showbiz
kiddo they can't all be Diana Ross at
the felt forum are you for season two
because we're probably gonna do what
we're gonna have to talk to mrs. or mr.
netflix about that what would you think
season two
well okay AJ and the Queen are about two
unlikely people who cross the United
States of America and become very good
friends
I love the element that we are traveling
I'd love for us to continue to travel
maybe AJ and the Queen go to Europe
maybe Aging in the Queen go to outer
space or maybe aging the Queen go to
Mexico in lava but I like crispy tacos
do you like soft tacos or crispy
toxicity yeah it's all about the crunch
yeah okay so if if a channeling were to
go to season two what would you like to
see happen I would like to see AJ Bale
robber
out of jail I want to see them and if
that doesn't happen in this one wait a
minute let me remember does that happen
in this one I don't go to jail do you go
to jail
does anybody go to jail in this series
yes they do they do we do okay I don't
remember but I'll take your word for it
and I took your word for it AJ the Queen
break out of prison AJ and the Queen
break out of prison that's a brilliant
idea but you know you have changed a lot
you know when we started you were 10 now
you're 11 and and that's the time of a
human's life where they grow up a lot do
you think it would take place years
later or it would take place where it
left off
I would think that in the second season
you see Ruby mm-hmm yeah arrested and
then like a couple of weeks later AJ
would bail you out of jail right when
they escaped to Washington DC and take
over and take and take over the White
House do you feel 11 do you feel 10 how
do you feel I do you feel older I feel
like it's a new year I feel like it's
2020 yes I do feel more mature but I
also feel like I'm still like 10 where I
still play and I still do things that a
10 year old module sure because I would
see you at the ADR where we go and put
in more vocals to the footage and when
you watch the footage from AJ and the
Queen do you think oh my goodness look
how much younger I look they're not
really I just think how proud this is
you know proud I am and that we worked
our butts off to this that we practiced
and we learn and we danced and we had
monologues and it was just a proud
moment this was so much fun we've got to
do this more often
really I think we've got a talk show
here I don't disagree but all right well
let's sign off for Entertainment Tonight
I'm RuPaul I'm a zg and we want you to
go and watch netflix new series AJ and
the Queen Thank You izzg Thank You
RuPaul Charles
[Music]